ja vielen Dank Stefan das war eine
Punktlandung in dieser Sekunde ruft die
sitzungspräsidentin hier die aktuelle
Stunde auf die von der Union beantragt
wurde ursprüngliche Titel war Leopard
Blockade der Bundesregierung beenden
kein vertrauensverhalten bei Verbündeten
verspielen jetzt hat es auch noch eine
Wortmeldung gegeben zum Geschäftseinsatz
und die CDU hat ja auch prominente
Redner aufgefahren also möglicherweise
spricht als erster Redner der Nachfolger
des äh jetzigen Bundeskanzlers deshalb
beantrage ich für die afd-fraktion die
Herbeirufung des Bundeskanzlers nach
Paragraph 42 GEO und Artikel 43 des
Grundgesetzes zu dieser wichtigen
Debatte die sich jetzt hier im Rahmen
der aktuellen Stunde anbahnt
Herr Brantner also zitiert für die AFD
den Bundeskanzler herbei der nicht auf
der Regierungsbank sitzt
von den anderen Fraktionen das ist nicht
der Fall dann lasse ich über diesen
Antrag abstimmen wer für den Antrag der
herbeizitierung ist denen und die bitte
ich jetzt um ihr Handzeichen
die afd-fraktion wer ist dagegen
sind die koalitionsfraktion und die
Linke wer enthält sich das ist die
Fraktion der
cdu/csu damit ist der Antrag abgelehnt
und ich komme jetzt zur aktuellen Stunde
die von der CDU CSU-Fraktion verlangt
worden ist zum Thema leopardblockade der
Bundesregierung beenden kein Vertrauen
bei Verbündeten verspielen als erstes
hat das Wort der Kollege Friedrich Merz
für die cdu/csu ja und die CDU geht
gleich mit ihrem fremden ran und er wird
sicherlich bemängeln dass der
Verteidigungsminister nicht da ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir hätten
selbstverständlich den Antrag auf diese
aktuelle Stunde zurückgezogen wenn der
Bundeskanzler heute morgen über die
Entscheidung des Bundeskabinetts nun
doch Leopard 2 Panzer an die Ukraine zu
liefern im Wege eine Regierungserklärung
nicht nur dieses Parlament sondern auch
die deutsche Öffentlichkeit informiert
hätte statt gestern Abend über die
Bild-Zeitung
ich will hier für die cdu/csu-fraktion
feststellen diese Entscheidung ist
richtig wir halten sie für angemessen
und ich will hinzufügen niemand in
diesem Haus tut sich mit einer solchen
Entscheidung leicht wir haben am 27
April 19 2022 hier im Deutschen
Bundestag gemeinsam beschlossen die auch
keine auch mit militärischer Ausrüstung
zu helfen wir haben beschlossen auch
schwere Waffen zu liefern im Laufe des
Jahres 2022 hat sich die Notwendigkeit
panzerwaffen zu liefern auch
panzerwaffen westlicher Bauart als immer
dringlicher erwiesen dies ist die
Meinung nicht nur der Ukraine gewesen
sondern dies ist auch die Auffassung
einer ganzen Reihe von alliierten und
Verbündeten in der Europäischen Union
und in der NATO gewesen allein die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und die
Bundesregierung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland haben eine frühere
Entscheidung darüber verhindert und
verzögert und ich will ausdrücklich dem
Eindruck widersprechen der heute morgen
in der Befragung des Bundeskanzlers
entstanden ist als ob dies alles
sozusagen im Konsens mit allen Partnern
in der Europäischen Union entschieden
worden sei das Gegenteil ist richtig
meine Damen und Herren
ich will es noch einmal unterstreichen
niemand von uns tut sich leicht mit
einer solchen schwerwiegenden
Entscheidung niemand aber wir hätten
schon erwartet dass es darüber hier im
Deutschen Bundestag eine intensivere
Diskussion über die Begründung der
Haltung der Bundesregierung in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten gegeben hätte
der Bundeskanzler der Bundeskanzler hat
die Öffentlichkeit und die Partner über
Wochen und Monate im Unklaren darüber
gelassen warum er denn eine solche
Entscheidung in diesem Umfang verzögert
warum hat er diese Entscheidung erst so
spät getroffen und meine Damen und
Herren ich füge eine zweite Beobachtung
oder eine zweite Feststellung hinzu die
schrillen Töne über die Waffen Lieferung
sind nicht aus der
Oppositionsfraktion gekommen die
schrillen Töne sind aus ihren Reihen
gekommen meine Damen und Herren aus FDP
und grüner Fraktionen insbesondere
hier sind hier immer zu einer sehr
abgewogenen Beurteilung der Lage
gekommen trotz ihrer Zwischenrufe meine
Damen und Herren wir haben allerdings
eines von ihnen erwartet und diese
Erwartung setzt sich fort Abstimmung in
solchen Fragen mit unseren Partnern in
der NATO und in der Europäischen Union
nicht eine Bundesregierung die getrieben
werden muss und dass sie getrieben
worden ist haben doch die Ereignisse
über den Jahreswechsel in aller
Deutlichkeit gezeigt bis hin zu der
rammsteinkonferenz in der letzten Woche
in der es offensichtlich ein schweres
Zerwürfnis zwischen dem amerikanischen
Verteidigungsminister und einigen
Vertretern der Bundesregierung auf
dieser Konferenz gegeben hat sie haben
eine meine Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung
die Bundesregierung hat eine Chance
vertan und bei dieser Gelegenheit waren
wir nun in großer Zahl dabei es waren
auch Kolleginnen und Kollegen der SPD
der Grünen und der FDP-Fraktion am
letzten Sonntag in Paris warum hat der
Bundeskanzler diese Gelegenheit nicht
genutzt mit dem französischen
Staatspräsidenten zusammen zu sagen dass
es in dieser Woche in dieser Frage eine
gemeinsame Entscheidung der Nato-Partner
der Partner in der Europäischen Union
und vor allem der französischen und der
deutschen Regierung gibt warum hat der
Bundeskanzler diese Chance nicht genutzt
bei ihnen in den Koalitionsfraktionen
werden aus diesen Auseinandersetzungen
der letzten Tage und Wochen einige
Verletzungen zurückbleiben daran werden
Sie sich gegenseitig regelmäßig erinnern
das aber ist ihre Sache bedauerlich aber
ihre Sache der Schaden der entstanden
ist meine Damen und Herren in der NATO
und in der Europäischen Union dass man
dieser Bundesregierung nicht trauen kann
dass man sie treiben muss dass sie zu
Entscheidungen gedrängt werden muss dass
sie zögert und zaudert und dass sie eben
nicht das tut was der Bundeskanzler
mehrfach hier in seinen Reden und heute
Mittag auch in seiner Befragung zum
Ausdruck gebracht hat nämlich mit den
Partnern zusammen zu entscheiden dieser
Schaden der bleibt auch über den Tag des
heutigen der heutigen Entscheidung
hinaus ich will es noch einmal
ausdrücklich unterstreichen die wir für
richtig halten wie früher hätte
getroffen werden müssen und die vor
allem hätte getroffen werden müssen ohne
diesen Schaden bei unseren Partnern in
der Europäischen Union und in der NATO
herzlichen Dank
Friedrich Merz der Fraktionschef der
cdu/csu und Parteivorsitzender der CDU
hier hat noch mal begründet warum die
Aktuelle Stunde trotzdem stattfinden der
Bundeskanzler habe hier seine Schritten
nicht begründet vor dem parlamentaren
übrigens der Bundesverteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius sitzt auf der
Regierungsbank und so ist es ja
eigentlich auch richtig Rolf Mütze nicht
jetzt bei dieser Debatte SPD
neben Kolleginnen und Kollegen zwei
Dinge lassen sich heute festhalten es
war ein
anstrengender aber notwendiger
Abstimmungsprozess der heute
seinen tragbaren Ergebnis gekommen ist
und auf der anderen Seite
zeigt sich heute wie wenig hilfreich ja
verantwortungslos meine Damen und Herren
Kommentare in den letzten Wochen waren
sie haben nicht geholfen sondern sie
haben insbesondere dem
Abstimmungsprozess den der Bundeskanzler
die die Bundesregierung von Anfang an
gewollt hat erschwert und ich bin mir
sicher nachträglich werden wir das noch
feststellen müssen und möglicherweise
auch bereuen hoffentlich von dem einen
oder anderen Dauerredner meine Damen und
Herren deswegen sage ich
gemeinsames Handeln ist
verantwortungsvoll und
voraussetzungsvoll weil es nämlich zwei
Dinge erreicht in einem Jahr eines
Krieges in der Ukraine nämlich das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht was die Ukraine
aus der Kater der Vereinten Nationen
herleitet allen von denen die
internationales Recht achten und Herr
Kollege Merz auf der anderen Seite die
Sicherheit Deutschlands fest zu machen
auch das ist der notwendige
Abstimmungsprozess mit den Partnern
voraussetzungsvoll sind diese beiden
Dinge eben nicht in Talkshows zu
erreichen sondern nur in harter Arbeit
in harter
Diplomatie und ich sage allen den
die immer wieder so laut rufen sie
verfügen nicht über das notwendige
Hintergrundwissen was erforderlich ist
und zum zweiten sie sind nicht in der
Lage und sie tragen auch Gott sei Dank
keine Verantwortung meine Damen und
Herren
und ja der Kollege merkt natürlich gab
es
Zwischenrufe die auch zwischen den
Koalitionspartnern gewesen war aber sie
sagen sie hätten sich an dieser Debatte
nicht beteiligt entschuldigung ich sage
entschuldigung aber ich muss Ihnen zwei
Sätze vor sie ich meine nicht Sie
persönlich sondern ihre Fraktion ihr
Kollege Michael Brand schreibt heute
morgen in der Fuldaer Zeitung
Zitat die Feigheit von Scholz vor
Ideologen und Zynikern die Mütze nicht
in der SPD hat bereits viele tausende
Menschen das Leben gekostet und droht
den Krieg nach Deutschland zu bringen
wie widerlich meine Damen und Herren
sind diese Sätze von einer angeblich
verantwortungsvoll
Opposition
der Kollege Merzig kann ihn nur raten
wenn sie wenn sie wenn sie überhaupt
Wünschen
orientieren sie sich an dem was für
unser Land auch wichtig gewesen ist
nämlich die deutsche Einheit wieder
herzustellen
nach schwierigen wegen aber auch nach
Einladung von Helmut Kohl ist Willy
Brandt mit ihm zusammen nach Berlin
gekommen als die Mauer fiel und das
finde ich zeigt konstruktive
Oppositionen und Offenheit zwischen
demokratischen Parteien so wünsche ich
mir in der Zukunft und deswegen sage ich
Ihnen auch sie werden auch kein Teil
zwischen die
Sozialdemokratien und Sozialdemokraten
bringen Lars Klingbeil wird gleich das
Wort ergreifen wir haben gestern ein
wichtiges Papier zur Diskussion über die
Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik nach dem
Angriffskrieg
Putins vorgelegt und ich sage Ihnen das
sind wichtige Bausteine für eine
zukünftige Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
die Sozialdemokraten und
Sozialdemokraten in diesem Jahrzehnt
weiter prägen wollen und meine Damen und
Herren zum Schluss
die Welt ist komplizierter als uns
manche vormachen wollen in
Twittermeldungen oder in kurzen
Kommentaren ich hatte Gelegenheit in der
Antwort auf den Bundeskanzler eine Karte
damals hier dem Deutschen Bundestag zu
zeigen welche Länder und wie groß diese
Länder sind die sich unserer
Schlussfolgerung aus dem Angriffskrieg
nicht anschließen und die wird man nicht
zur Seite schieben können sondern mit
denen muss man offen in einem
diplomatischen versuchen Konsens zu
treten und genau das hat der
Bundeskanzler getan und das hat uns die
Chance eröffnet meine Damen und Herren
nachdem China das nukleare Tabu
bekräftigt hat nachdem auf dem G20
Gipfel das nukleare Tabu bekräftigt
worden ist dass wir diese
Handlungsfreiheit haben die wir heute
gehabt haben nachdem der Bundeskanzler
seiner Entscheidung deine Entscheidung
glaube ich auch der USA und Frankreich
in den nächsten Stunden folgen wird zu
machen und deswegen sage ich kluge
Außenpolitik ist mehr als die Lieferung
von Waffen und das ist auch das
Versprechen der sozialdemokratischen
Fraktion und Partei vielen Dank
Rolf Mützenich hat hier Friedrich Merz
noch einmal vorgeführt dass durchaus
auch unangemessene Zwischenrufe aus der
Opposition CDU und CSU gekommen sind
nach dem März ja gesagt hat in die
Zwischenrufe sein alle aus der Ampel
gewesen Dino krupala jetzt
fraktionsschrift der AFD
frau Präsidentin ich hätte mir natürlich
schon mal sehr gewünscht wenn der Titel
dieser aktuellen Stunde leopardblockade
immer noch Bestand hätte das hätte auch
die afd-fraktion absolut begrüßt das
muss ich als allererstes sagen und wenn
ich aktuell auch diese Debatte jetzt
hier verfolgt habe Herr Merz sie hatten
ja einiges hier schon gesprochen mit
Ihnen als Bundeskanzler hätten wir
bereits Kampfflugzeuge geliefert also
von daher ihre Heuchelei hier an dieser
Stelle das hat eigentlich gezeigt sieht
gehen genauso in diese Kriegstreiber
rein wie FDP und Grüne das ist
mittlerweile die Aufgabe der größten
Opposition in diesem Land
ich muss Ihnen sagen ich und wir fühlen
mit der ukrainischen Bevölkerung auch
vor Ort denn Kriegsangst und das ist das
Thema Kriegsangst verspüren mittlerweile
die Deutschen auch hier in unserem Land
aber werden die maßlosen und vor allen
Dingen die egozentrischen Forderungen
einiger ukrainischen Politiker die sich
ja jetzt schon wieder per Twitter
absondern noch immer mehr Waffen und
schneller zu liefern oder bewirken sie
im Prinzip eigentlich auch mehr als nur
diesen Brandbeschleuniger kann die
eu-kraine überhaupt gewinnen stehen hier
die Einsatz und der Einsatz der Mittel
im Verhältnis zum Ergebnis welche
Strategie verfolgt eigentlich die
Bundesregierung das ist auch Scholz
heute offen geblieben in der Frage Runde
wie gestellt wurde wollen sie eigentlich
den Bündnisfall provozieren so erscheint
es mittlerweile vielen in der deutschen
Bevölkerung die immer immer mehr Angst
haben dazu alle haben sie auch die Frage
wo sind eigentlich die Waffen geblieben
die wir und andere Länder schon
geliefert haben sind diese von der
Ukraine oder noch im Einsatz oder hat
der Russe diese längst zerstört auch das
nicht beantwortet sie suggerieren hier
den Bürgern das mit der Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern Leopard Russland besiegt
werden kann
wie viele Panzer möchten Sie denn
weltweit zusammensuchen um die
ausstattungsstärke der russischen Armee
zu erreichen bzw auch zu übertreffen
laut Statista verfügt Russland 2022 über
circa 12.500 Kampfpanzer die Ukraine im
übrigen über ca 2600 damit stehen der
ukrainischen Armee fast 9 mal so viel
Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung wie aktuell
der Bundeswehr
Bundesverteidigungsministerium hat ja
dazu Auskunft gegeben mit ungefähr 289
Leopard 2 Panzern das sind die Fakten
nun meldet sich natürlich die
Rüstungsindustrie Blackrock Herz reibt
sich schon die Hände rein Metall hat
wohl 239 Panzer die innerhalb von zwei
Jahren bereits Stunden und ich frage sie
warum wurden diese nicht längst für die
Bundeswehr im übrigen atüchtigt diese
Panzer Werte Kollegen schauen Sie sich
die Lieferung aus der Bundeswehr
beständigen bzw die zusätzlichen
Beschaffung an die wir bereits für
diesen Krieg getätigt haben wie lange
braucht es wohl um unsere Bestände der
Bundeswehr wieder aufzubauen sie und
zuvor die CDU plündern unsere Bundeswehr
aus wie sieht es wenn aktuell mit der
Verteidigungsbereitschaft der Bundeswehr
aus oder sind wir nun vollends von
Allianzen und Bündnissen abhängig meine
Damen und Herren mit ihren
Entscheidungen verlängern Sie aktiv
einen Konflikt und versperren sich
friedensverhandlung sie laufen Sehnen
Auges direkt ins offene Feuer ich muss
es offen sagen direkt in den Dritten
Weltkrieg was ist also das Ziel der
Bundesregierung und auch der größten
Opposition CDU wollen Sie diesen Krieg
zu dem unseren machen und Deutschland
wieder in die Dunkelheit stürzen erst
liefern wir Ausrüstung dann leichte
Waffen dann schwere Waffen was ist das
nächste sind es dann deutsche Soldaten
die wir liefern und die einsatzbereit
sein sollen
am 2 februar am zweiten Februar gedenken
wir dem 80 jahrestag der Schlacht um
Stalingrad mit all seinen kriegststoten
ich empfehle Ihnen gerade von der FDP
allen den Besuch einer
Kriegsgräberstätte wo auch ich während
meiner Auslandsreisen regelmäßig einen
Kranz niederlege oder hier direkt vor
den Toren Berlins an den Seelower Höhen
fast jeder in diesem Hohen Haus kann
dort Familienmitglieder wiederfinden die
im Krieg zu Tode kam
die Lieferung von Waffen wird das Leid
vergrößern und viel schlimmer es werden
zahllose Tote zu beklagen sein dieser
Krieg hilft niemand auf dem europäischen
und asiatischen Kontinent und der glaubt
mit Waffenlieferung Frieden zu schaffen
ist wirklich mehr als naiv Druck erzeugt
Gegendruck
Allianzen und Freundschaften sind
aufrichtig und wahr wenn alle Seiten
alle Seiten die Last gemeinsam tragen in
diesem Fall werden wir als Deutsche und
wird Europa wieder mal einseitig
belastet der Krieg findet wieder vor
unserer Haustür statt unsere sogenannten
Freunde aus den Vereinigten Staaten
heizen die Situation immer weiter an
deren Rüstungsindustrie macht wieder
gute Geschäfte und kann die maroden
Staatsfinanzen sanieren schließlich
müssen sie sich die USA nicht um die
Sicherheit ihres Kontinents sorgen und
diese Sicherheit ist auf den Kontinent
Europa in Gefahr und genau damit muss
Schluss sein Bündnisse ja Allianzen ja
aber doch nicht um den Preis der
Selbstaufgabe europa braucht Frieden und
muss eine souveräne Stellung in der Welt
erlangen und wir müssen zuerst den
Interessen unseres Landes und unserer
Bürger dienen sie haben als
Bundesregierung die Aufgabe Schaden von
Land und Leuten abzuwenden werden sie
endlich dieser Aufgabe gerecht
der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
afd-fraktion hier in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die er noch mal aktueller
geworden ist durch die Entscheidungen zu
Leopard 2 Panzern nächster Redner ist
Jürgen Trittin der außer politische
Sprecher der Grünen Fraktion
das schicken sie an märz und Herr
Dobrindt in die Bütt und dann hat sich
das Thema erledigt und zur Strafe müssen
Sie dann die Reden von Herrn krupala
anhören die Reden eines Mitglieds einer
Partei von dem ein Abgeordneter Jahre
lang ein Büro in Moskau betrieben hat so
viel zu Ernsthaftigkeit ihre
Argumentation an dieser Stelle
es ist gut dass der Bundeskanzler heute
für Klarheit gesorgt hat Deutschland ist
nicht nur der zweitgrößte zivile
Unterstützer der Ukraine wir stellen
Zehntausende von Generatoren um den
Menschen die Last der Kälte durch den
russischen Bomben Terror zu nehmen vor
allem aber deutschland ist mit den USA
und mit Großbritannien einer der drei
großen militärischen Unterstützer der
Ukraine in ihrem Kampf gegen die
russische Aggression sind deutsche
gebhardpanzer die iranische Drohnen
abschießen es waren deutsche
Raketenwerfer und die Panzerhaubitze
2000 die die Ukraine die Befreiung
besetzter Gebiete ermöglicht haben und
damit hört es nicht auf am Freitag
wurden in Ramstein neue Zusagen gemacht
das vielleicht größte militärische
Unterstützungspaket am Montag ist im Rat
für auswärtige Beziehung
noch einmal 500 Millionen in die
europäische peacefacellity zur
Beschaffung von Rüstungsgütern gegangen
das heißt 125 davon kommen aus
Deutschland das alles verschweigen Sie
Herr Merz das alles verschweigen sie
weil es ihnen unangenehm ist aber für
die Ukraine ist diese Hilfe
wie sage ich Ihnen auch sie ist
existenziell aber sie reicht nicht wir
müssen mehr machen nehmen wir ernst was
wir täglich erfahren was unsere Dienste
sagen
dann steht die Ukraine vor einer großen
Frühjahrsoffensive Russlands
der geplante aufwuchs der russischen
Armee auf 1,5 Millionen möglicherweise
zwei Millionen soldateninnen und Söldner
das Lehren aller Depots zeigt worauf
Putin setzt er will mit einer
Materialschlacht die Ukraine überrennen
und diese zynische Politik kalkuliert
den Tod von tausenden Russen ein vor
Sonne da vor bachmut völlig heizt er
jeden Tag 300 Menschenleben alle Zeichen
stehen auf eine russische Großoffensive
und es ist zynische Menschenverachtung
dieser Angriffskrieg diese Kriegsführung
ist verbrecherisch und das ist der
Hintergrund für diese Debatte
und ich würde mir wünschen
liebe Frau Wagenknecht Liebe seven
daddelem wenn Sie Ihren
antimilitaristischen Furor einmal nur
einmal gegen diese Politik von Putin
verwenden würden so aber sind ihre
Einlassungen dem Ernst der Lage nicht
angemessen und ich will das mit aller
diplomatischen Zurückhaltung sagen dem
Ernst der Lage war auch nicht das
angemessen was die polnische Regierung
an dieser Frage veranstaltet hat ich bin
froh dass Annalena baerbock dies auf den
Boden der Tatsachen zurückgeholt hat man
kann schlecht darüber reden über einen
angeblich abgelehnten Antrag den man
noch nicht einmal gestellt hat
wir wollen
wir wollen ernsthaft verhindern dass
Russland die Ukraine überrennt
das ist in unserem ureigenen Interesse
wer es belohnt das mit gewaltgrenzen in
Europa verändert werden der gefährdet
die Sicherheit und den Frieden auch in
Deutschland
und ich weiß die Menschen hier im Lande
sind gespalten auch über die Lieferung
der Panzer
ich selber bin überzeugt davon ohne sie
wird die Ukraine Putin nicht stoppen
können aber die Menschen die das
Ablehnen sie haben Gründe dafür
ein Grund ist die Furcht vor einer
Eskalation vor einer Rutschbahn an deren
Ende ein Krieg der NATO mit Russland
stehen könnte
ja wir wollen die Ukraine unterstützen
aber wir wollen keine militärische
Auseinandersetzung zwischen der Nato und
Russland und es gibt die Gefahr der
Eskalation es gibt sie in jedem Krieg
der hat schon klausewitz darauf
hingewiesen
aber die Gefahr der Eskalation darf kein
Freibrief sein für Verbrecher die
glauben sie hätten die eskalationshoheit
die Antwort auf die Gefahr der
Eskalation muss sein wir müssen diese
Gefahr mindern und dabei die Ukraine
unterstützen das Rezept der Minderung
der Eskalation das liegt daran wir
müssen in der NATO Gemeinsamkeit
herstellen Gemeinsamkeit innerhalb der
NATO ist der beste Schutz gegen die
Eskalation und ich bin froh dass es im
Bundeskanzler
in freundlichen Gesprächen wie er das
genannt hat gelungen ist die USA zu
überzeugen sich an der Lieferung von
Panzern zu beteiligen Putins Rechnung
die NATO zu Spalten zwischen Europa und
den USA geht nicht auf so geht Führung
Führung geht nicht übrigens liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
in Alleingänge Führung in der
multipolaren Welt geht nur im
Gemeinsamkeit vielen Dank
das Wort für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
Frau Präsident meine Damen und Herren
vor 11 Monaten begann der Krieg Russland
gegen die Ukraine
280.000 tote Soldatinnen und Soldaten
auf beiden Seiten 10.000 zivile Opfer
und es klar zu sagen wir verurteilen den
Versuch Putins lieber Jürgen Trittin
Grenzen in Europa zu verschieben auf das
Schärfste da gibt es überhaupt keinen
Zweifel in der Linken aber liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich hoffe dass
es in dem Hohen Haus auch ein Konsens
gibt dass dieser Krieg schnellstmöglich
enden soll es muss Schluss sein mit dem
Sterben mitten in Europa liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dafür
brauche ich
dslation und nicht Eskalation der
Bundeskanzler hat eben in der
regierungsbefragung gesagt wir werden
alles tun um eine Eskalation zu
verhindern was ist dann aber die
Realität wenn man sich die letzten 11
Monate anschaut es gab immer weiter eine
Eskalation das ist die Wahrheit ja ich
weiß in diesem Hohen Haus gibt es
offenbar eine Mehrheit dafür Leopard
besser in den Krieg zu schicken die
cdu/csu-fraktion die Grünen mindestens
Teile der SPD und Teile der FDP sehen
Kampfpanzer als ein Beitrag zum Frieden
meine Fraktion ausdrücklich nicht meine
Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler hat
jetzt nachgegeben und ich sage deutlich
wir finden das falsch und wenn der neue
Verteidigungsminister sagt die ersten
Leopard Panzer werden in drei Monaten in
der Ukraine sein was für ein Verständnis
das Ziel muss sein dass es in drei
Monaten keinen Krieg mehr gibt in der
Ukraine meine Damen und Herren das muss
das Ziel sein angesichts der russischen
Ressourcen und der Bereitschaft der
russischen Führung Soldaten zu verheizen
wird dieser Krieg so weiter eskalieren
und es werden weitere hunderttausende
Menschen Leben geopfert werden wenn wir
nicht aus der Kriegslogik aussteigen
meine Damen und Herren ich empfehle
Ihnen dringend hören Sie nicht länger
auf ihr Bauchgefühl es belügt sie
sondern sie sich nicht in den schlafz
des Boulevards der den Krieg anheizt
hören sie auf Experten ich will nur ein
zitieren der Rang höchste sie sollten
bisschen ruhiger und entspannter und
nachdenklicher sein bei den Grünen
erinnern Sie sich mal wo sie herkommen
der Rang höchste US-General Mike Melli
hat gesagt die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
ukrainischen militärischen Sieges
definiert als Rauswurf der Russen aus
der gesamten Ukraine einschließlich der
von ihnen beanspruchten Krim ist
militärisch gesehen nicht sehr hoch es
gibt eine selten Übereinstimmung des
Generals mit meiner Position und jetzt
hören wir seit Tagen von ihm wer nur
nachdenklich ist Kampfpanzer zu liefern
ist ein Putin Freund ehrlich gesagt sie
beleidigen mit solchen Dünnpfiff nicht
nur ihren eigenen Intellekt sondern auch
die Mehrheit der starken Gemeinschaft
meine Damen und Herren das ist die
Wahrheit die Lieferung von Kampfpanzern
Markt im Deutschen Bundestag eine
Mehrheit haben in der Bevölkerung ist
das gegen Gegenteil der Fall in
Ostdeutschland ist nicht mal ein Drittel
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger dafür ein
Jahr zum Leopard beschädigt dort
ausdrücklich auch die Demokratie meine
Damen und Herren das ist die Wahrheit
mehr Nachdenklichkeit des angesagt ich
höre jetzt auch immer wieder Deutschland
wäre international isoliert wenn das
wenn wir keine leopardlieferer würden
was für ein Unsinn
die Mehrzahl der internationalen
Staatengemeinschaft hat nicht eine
einzige Gewehrkugel geliefert in diesen
kriegswahnsinn die Mehrheit der
internationalen Gemeinschaft weiß dass
eine atomacht nicht militärisch zu
besiegen ist die weiß das Kampfpanzer
kein Frieden bringen meine Damen und
Herren jede Zurückhaltung jede
Zurückhaltung deutsche Kampfpanzer in
eine Schlacht mit russischen Truppen zu
schicken ist mehr als gerechtfertigt
Angesicht unserer Geschichte 27
Millionen sowjetbürgerinnen und so wird
Bürger diese historische Schuld werden
auch dazu dass man nachdenklich ist
meine Damen und
die Wahrheit ist was die Wahrheit ist
der die gestrige Meldung Aktienkurs von
Rheinmetall auf Rekordniveau ja die
klatschen in die Hände Rheinmetall kommt
in die Dax das ist ja ein wunderbares
Ergebnis meine Damen und Herren meine
Damen und Herren wer ohne strategisches
Fundament immer mehr und immer schwerere
Waffen liefern will der bleibt auch
nicht bei Kampfpanzer entstehen morgen
Kriegsschiffe mehr hat Jürgen Trittin
gerade gesagt mehr morgen Kriegsschiffe
übermorgen Kampfflugzeuge Tornados
Eurofighter flugverbotssohn dann hatte
Soldaten wo soll denn das Ändern Markus
keinen immerhin von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik der hat bei
Spiegel Online dazu folgendes
geschrieben mit einem derartigen
Freibrief ließ sich auch die Lieferung
taktischer Nuklearwaffen an die
ukrainische Streitkräfte rechtfertigen
ja selbst so ein Unsinn wird gefordert
ich kann die Bundesregierung nur
auffordern sagen sie Nein zur weiteren
Eskalation legen sie endlich eine
abgestimmte europäische Frieden
Initiative vor da sollten Sie Ihre
Anstrengung deutlich verstärken meine
Damen und Herren dankeschön
Dietmar Bartsch hat hier für die
Linksfraktion gesprochen und die
vorherigen Redner kritisiert und richtig
ist der Obmann im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
für die FDP-Fraktion und der nächste
Rednern dieser aktuellen Stunde
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren also zu Beginn der
Faschismus hat uns mehrere Millionen
Tote in Europa gebracht und hat uns in
Krieg und Elend gestürzt
das hat der braune gemacht und ich
glaube die Partei die am nächsten kommt
es die von Herrn koopaland diesen Haus
und der Sozialismus hat Hunderte von
Millionen Menschen in Armut Hunger und
in den Tod geführt von den berühmten
Führern die offensichtlich alle bei
ihnen noch in dem Büros hängen ich
erinnere da an Maus Stalin und Wiese
alle hießen man sieht was der
Sozialismus gebracht hat die
sozialistischen Republiken im Nahen
Osten die sozialistischen Republiken in
Nord im Norden von Südamerika Venezuela
alles ganz großes Kino und dann hier
belehren an diesem historischen Tag wo
wir nach vielen vielen vielen Debatten
die es auch in unserer Koalition gibt
entsprechend zu
Überzeugung gelangt sind dass wir die
Panzer liefern und bei aller allerliebe
ja heute habe ich viel von Willy Brandt
gehört und auch von Helmut Schmidt ich
erinnere da auch anhand Dietrich Genter
Waldshut die alle zum Frieden in Europa
mit beigetragen haben und auch diese
würden heute hier stehen und sagen wir
können nicht anders als unseren Frieden
den wir in Europa mit viel Mühe
erarbeitet haben gemeinsam zu
verteidigen und die Verteidigung unseres
Friedens in Europa findet derzeit in der
Ukraine statt und das ist
nummerhistorischer Fakt und
dementsprechend ist es völlig richtig
dass diese von uns getragene
Bundesregierung zu dieser Entscheidung
gekommen ist und das steht für mich
völlig außer Frage die Ukraine hat uns
um diese Panzer gebeten sie brauchen sie
in ihrem Verteidigungskampf für Freiheit
und Demokratie gegen die Garantie Macht
die ihnen selber 1994 zugesagt hat dass
ihre nationale Integrität ihre
Bündnisfreiheit garantiert ist im
Budapester memorand um 1997 schriftlich
noch mal bestätigt die Russische
Föderation ist der Aggressor und nicht
diese Bundesregierung oder wer auch
immer hier von Kriegstreiberei spricht
und diese narrative die die ganze Zeit
aufgewiesen werden die wir hören müssen
jeden Tag über telegram und so weiter
verbreitet die sind ihre narrative die
sie versuchen den deutschen Volk
einzutrichtern und diese narrative sind
schlicht und ergreifend falsch es ist
Putin der am 24.02 vergangenen Jahres
den Angriffsbefehl gegeben hat der dafür
gesorgt hat dass
150.000 Soldaten in ukrainisches
Territorium eingefallen sind der einen
vollen Angriff auf die Ukraine fährt und
es ist verdammt noch mal die Pflicht des
Westens wir sind nämlich auch
garantiemächte in Form der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika des United Kingdom
und Frankreichs und damals hat
Deutschland auch entsprechend an dem
Vertrag mitgearbeitet 94 beim Budapester
memorantum diesen Freunden in der
Ukraine zu helfen die ein demokratisch
gewählten legitimierten Präsidenten
haben und der vom ukrainischen Volk
dorthin gewählt worden ist wo er
hingewählt worden ist und was sie hier
versuchen darzustellen dass wir
Kriegstreiber werden ausgerechnet Rolf
Mütze nicht der immer noch im
Schützengraben vom Bonn liegt und ganz
genau weiß wofür er kämpft ja oder die
alte Dame SPD die jetzt ihre
außenpolitischen Grundlagen geändert hat
und wer klingt weil das gestern
vorgelegt hat auch bei uns in der Partei
die wir verwurzelt sind auch ebenfalls
im KFZ e-prozess OSZE und allem aber wir
haben feststellen müssen dass unsere
ganzen multilateralen
Komponenten nicht genügt haben und wer
war es denn der vor dem Krieg nach
Peking gereist ist es war Putin der vor
den Olympischen Spielen dort war und
seine Versicherungspolice gezogen hat
die Chinesen sehen momentan dass das
kein schlauer Akt war und versuchen sich
halbwegs wieder daraus zurückzuziehen
aber solange Putin diesen Krieg nicht
beenden möchte Friedensverhandlungen
ablehnt und
waffenstillstandsverhandlung was ich
heute morgen hier gehört habe die
Ukrainer haben kurz vor Tores lustig vom
Boris Johnson davon abhalten lassen dass
es zufrieden kommt das ist hane Büchener
Unsinn ist Verschwörungstheorie und ist
diesem Hause hier in Wahrheit wirklich
nicht würdig ich bin dankbar Liebe SPD
das sämtliche Bremsen für den Kanzler
nun gelöst worden sind ich bin dankbar
der Grünen die kommen nämlich aus der
Friedensbewegung dass sie sofort erkannt
haben worum es geht bei diesen Krieg und
ich bin dankbar unserem Finanzminister
das wird die 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr zur Verfügung gestellt haben
und ich bin dankbar dass die größte
Oppositionspartei Gott sei Dank die
Union und nicht die anderen beiden die
hier noch sitzen müssen dass die im
Endeffekt unseren Kurs mittragen und
dass wir gemeinsam der Ukraine zur Seite
stehen darum geht es in diesem ganzen
Fall und diesen ganzen Krieg und
hoffentlich können wir den Frieden in
Europa so erhalten wie in unsere
Gründungsväter in dieser Republik
gemeinsam aufgebaut haben vielen Dank
Alexander Dobrindt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir kritisieren
nicht die Entscheidung dass die
Bundesregierung den Leopard 2 Panzer
liefern will wir unterstützen sogar
diese Entscheidung wir haben sie sogar
eingefordert aber wir kritisieren die
Art des Umgangs mit dieser Lieferung das
wie und wann und vor allem diesen
untauglichen Versuch das Zögern über
Wochen und Monate jetzt zur Strategie zu
erklären meine Damen und Herren
das Problem lieber Kollege Mütze nicht
das war doch nicht dass sie sich mit
allen Bündnispartnern abstimmen mussten
das Problem war doch dass unsere
Bündnispartner längst abgestimmt waren
aber die Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung gefehlt hat das ist die
Wahrheit an der Stelle
da gibt es ja eine Reihe von
Wortmeldungen die das auch belegen weil
sie dazwischen scheinen das würde nicht
stimmen die rammstein-konferenz die war
am Freitag am vergangenen die
Wortmeldungen der Nachricht kann Ihnen
die vorlesenfausstrack Zimmermann hat
sich ja öffentlich gegenüber den Medien
geäußert und dann von gesprochen dass
Deutschland leider gerade versagt hat
wörtlich davon gesprochen die Geschichte
schaut auf uns und Deutschland hat
leider gerade versagt man könnte das
beliebig weiter aufzählen an dieser
Stelle und ich will auch Ihnen sagen
sehr geehrter Kollege Mütze nicht ich
verstehe natürlich die Empörung über
manche Twittermeldungen die es gibt vor
allem gegenüber ihrer Person aber dann
bitte aufregend über die Meldungen die
aus ihrer eigenen Koalition kommen Ihnen
bezüglich
der polnische Ministerpräsident hat der
Ampel noch vor zwei Tagen vorgeworfen
dass die Verzögerungstaktik inakzeptabel
sei er hat sogar den Verdacht geäußert
dass Deutschland die Leopard Allianz
sabotieren wollte der lettische
Außenminister hat noch mal deutlich
gesagt vor zwei Tagen es gäbe überhaupt
keine guten Argumente mehr warum man
Kampfpanzer dicht bereitstellen könnte
meine Damen und Herren anscheinend
wussten bis zum heutigen Tag unsere
europäischen Partner nicht dass sie
diese Entscheidung treffen wollen das
nennen sie abgestimmt von wegen meine
Damen und Herren
der Bundeskanzler hat hier
vorhin in der regierungsbefragung gesagt
er trifft keine Entscheidung die eine
Gefahr für die Sicherheit Deutschlands
ist unsere Partner empfinden ihr Zögern
als das größte Risiko für die Sicherheit
Deutschlands
der französische Präsident hat es ihnen
auch noch mal am Wochenende ins
Stammbuch geschrieben man wird nicht nur
an seinen Entscheidungen gemessen
sondern auch an den Entscheidungen die
man nicht trifft mehr muss man dazu
eigentlich nicht sagen bezüglich
abgestimmt und ich darf auch an der
Stelle sagen weil Lars klingt weil sie
hier noch zu Wort kommen was den guten
Umgang mit unseren Partnern anbelangt
sie fordern ja ständig die Führungsrolle
Deutschlands in Europa ein was diese
Ampel aber einnimmt ist die
Außenseiterrolle in Europa so kann man
nicht zusammenarbeiten mit unseren
Partnern
wir haben am 28 April vergangenen Jahres
eine Entscheidung gemeinschaftlich hier
getroffen die schweren Waffen in die
Ukraine zu liefern jetzt neun Monate
neun Monate nach dieser Entscheidung
werden dann möglicherweise Leopard
Panzer geliefert das ist eine Latenzzeit
die ist diese Krisensituation
schlichtweg nicht angemessen mitten in
einem Krieg mitten in Europa und der
Bundeskanzler hat heute davon gesprochen
dass das die neue Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit sei neun Monate Zaudern
und zögern das ist die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit die unsere Partner von
ihnen wahrnehmen so schaut es aus
und ich bitte Sie dringend an dieser
Stelle eine neue
deutschland-geschwindigkeit an den Tag
zu legen wenn es darum geht die 100
Milliarden umzusetzen der Bundesminister
der Verteidigung ihre Vorgängerin hat
versprochen zehn Milliarden Euro an
munitionsbeschaffung im Jahr 2022
umzusetzen davon ist nichts aber auch
gar nichts geschehen die zwei Prozent
Ziel sie stehen nicht im Haushalt auch
für die nächsten Jahre nicht das ist
ihre Aufgabe das umzusetzen ich darf an
der Stelle der Bundesminister Pistorius
aber auch die Gelegenheit wahrnehmen
hier im Deutschen Bundestag ihnen für
ihr neues Amt viel Erfolg zu wünschen
aufrichtig viel Erfolg an dieser Stelle
darf Ihnen aber auch mitteilen sie haben
als Bundesminister auch das Recht in
einer aktuellen Stunde zu sprechen
Herr Kollege das waren die letzten Worte
erwähnt hat wir wollen alle den Frieden
lieber Kollege Bartsch Frieden wird
nicht dadurch geschaffen dass man der UK
eine die Selbstverteidigung nicht
wahrnehmen lasst Frieden wird dadurch
geschaffen wenn die Ukraine sich selbst
verteidigen kann und diesen Status
stellen wir hier meine Damen und Herren
Alexander Dobrindt war das für die
Unionsfraktion die SPD will sich neu
sortieren in ihrer Position zur außen
und Sicherheitspolitik und SPD-Chef Lars
Klingmann hat gerade am Montag einen
Entwurf für ein Positionspapier den
Partei Präsidium vorgelegt jetzt spricht
er hier im Deutschen Bundestag frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege Dobrindt
vielleicht noch mal im Büro bescheid
sagen ich glaube das war die Rede die
gestern geschrieben wurde und da wurden
die neuen Realitäten durch Entscheidung
der Bundesregierung nicht eingearbeitet
aber lassen Sie mich doch mal darüber
reden worum es hier eigentlich geht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
erleben seit dem 24 Februar ein brutalen
ein völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
durch Russland gegen die Ukraine die
haben hier im Parlament viele
weitreichende Entscheidungen getroffen
wir haben tiefgehende ernste Diskussion
geführt über eine Situation von der wir
alle gehofft hatten dass wir sie nie
wieder erleben müssen das mitten in
Europa mit militärischer Gewalt Grenzen
verschoben werden dass ein souveräner
Staat in seiner Integrität angebrochen
wird angegriffen wird und dass wir jeden
Tag erleben müssen dass Menschen durch
Putins Armee sterben
und wissen Sie ich habe in den letzten
Tagen mich manches Mal gefragt ob eine
Diskussion wie wir sie geführt haben
ob sie angemessen ist dieser Situation
diesem Leid dem die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer ausgesetzt sind und ich will
deswegen hier ganz zu Beginn sagen weil
es nie außer Acht geraten darf putin ist
der Kriegsverbrecher wir senden hier aus
Deutschland seit dem 24 Februar ein
Signal wo ich auch stolz darauf bin dass
wir das häufig und oftmals in großer
Einigkeit tun wir stehen als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland als Regierung
als Parlament doch in der großen Zahl
solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und darum muss es doch auch in einer
aktuellen Stunde wie heute gehen
und
ich finde auch dass wir
immer wieder betonen müssen welche
Schritte wir gegangen sind seit dem 24
Februar wir haben jetzt einen Grundsatz
der deutschen außensicherheitspolitik
gebrochen
und wir liefern Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebiet damit die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine die mutig kämpfen und wir alle
bewundern diesen Mut damit Sie sich
selbst verteidigen können und wir sehen
doch auch dass es unsere Waffen unsere
Unterstützung sind die helfen das
Geländegewinne da sind das Städte
zurückerobert werden dass die russische
Aggression zurückgedrängt wird
und ich bin dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
dankbar für die Signale die an den
ersten sechs Tagen seiner amtszeitgesetz
hat und ich will das hier mal sagen weil
das in den Hintergrund geraten ist eine
Konferenz in Ramstein bei der die
Bundesregierung ein Paket mit 1,1
Milliarden auf den Weg gebracht hat 1,1
Milliarden an militärischer
Unterstützung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist gut dass die
Bundesregierung das getan hat und ich
bin dem Minister ich bin dem
Bundeskanzler und allen anderen die
daran beteiligt waren dankbar für das
klare Signal das von Rammstein
ausgegangen ist
und wenn der Kollege Dobrindt hier sagt
man unterstützt die Entscheidung des
Bundeskanzlers aber es sei die Art und
Weise wieder mit umgegangen wurde dann
will ich das jetzt schon gerne mal
konkret wissen der Bundeskanzler hat
immer klar gesagt es gibt drei
Prinzipien bestimmen und Senken ab und
Bündnis wir werden selbst nicht
Kriegspartei und es gibt keine
Alleingänge lieber Kollege Dobrindt
welcher dieser drei Grundsätze stößt
denn bei der Union auf Widerspruch das
finde ich schon spannend dass mal zu
hören aber da hat er sich nicht zu
geäußert übrigens auch die klare Aussage
von Tag eins wir bewegen uns im Bündnis
und es gibt für uns keine rote Linien
wenn es darum geht dass
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine zu
unterstützen
aber ich sag hier auch das sind Zeiten
von großer Tragweite von Krieg und
Frieden wo wir doch alle auch in den
Wahlkreisen sorgen und Unsicherheiten
erleben wo doch Nachdenklichkeit und
auch abwägen mal erlaubt sein muss
wusste doch darum geht dass man nicht
dann Dinge verkündet wenn irgendwer das
gerade auf Twitter oder in den großen
fordert sondern dann wenn Dinge auch im
Bündnis geklärt sind und ich will das
hier klar sagen das ist ein großer
diplomatischer Erfolg von Olaf Scholz
und von dieser Bundesregierung dass man
jetzt im Bündnis abgestimmt mit
europäischen mit den transatlantischen
Partnern dass man dort einen Schritt
weiter geht und dass wir jetzt die
Ukraine stärken dadurch dass wir
Kampfpanzer liefern das ist ein großer
Erfolg und ich ertrage nicht wie das
rein geredet wird von der Opposition
und wie das Friedrich Merz
ich will das hier schon sagen das genüle
aus der Union in den letzten Tagen
Alexander Dobrindt hätte es jetzt machen
können dass man sich für Michael Brandt
und seine unhaltbaren Worte hier
entschuldigt auch das hat er nicht getan
aber die CDU
Herr märz die CDU ist doch die Partei
von Konrad Adenauer der für die
Westintegration steht die Partei von
Helmut Kohl die für die europäische
Integration steht von Angela Merkel die
dafür gesorgt hat dass Deutschland einen
guten internationalen Ruf hat und dieses
knölle sie treten den Rasen kaputt als
Union auch sie fallen der
Bundesregierung in den Rücken das ist
doch unwürdig was sie machen Herr Merz
und ich sage Ihnen sie können das besser
bitte kommen Sie zum Schluss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche mir
dass wir eine Diskussion in der
Tragweite von Krieg und Frieden dass wir
sie angemessener führen als sich das in
den letzten Tagen erlebt habe ich bin
der Bundesregierung dankbar dafür dass
wir die Ukraine stärken und ich wünsche
mir dass wir das geschlossen als
DemokratInnen und Demokraten weiter tun
vielen Dank
ich möchte nur am Rande darauf hinweisen
dass die Geschäftsführung für jede Frau
und jeder Mann in diesem Plenarsaal gilt
ein aktuelle Stunde besteht aber in fünf
Minuten Beitrag und sein fünf Minuten 45
Sekunden ist ja schon ein bisschen viel
weil alle anderen auch die Anspruch
hätten dann entsprechend berücksichtigen
zu werden
als nächster hält das Wort die Kollegen
die Bora Thüringen Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen zu Recht diskutieren wir
seit Monaten über Waffenlieferungen in
die Ukraine es ist wichtig dass wir auch
in dieser Frage solidarisch an der Seite
der Ukraine stehen die Ukraine muss in
der Lage sein sich selbst verteidigen zu
können aber
Solidarität mit der Ukraine hat viele
Facetten sie hat zum Beispiel eine
innenpolitische Facette Solidarität
zeigt sich auch darin wie wir mit
ukrainischen geflüchteten hier vor Ort
umgehen
und auch wenn die Hilfsbereitschaft in
der Bevölkerung ungebrochen ist so frage
ich mich ehrlich gesagt bei den
Äußerungen ihres Parteivorsitzenden
lieben Union wie es wirklich um die
Solidarität steht christlich
demokratische Werte sind meiner Meinung
nach auf jeden Fall anders aus
wir alle hier wissen wie schlecht die
humanitäre Lage in der Ukraine ist
Russland setzt gezielt explosionswaffen
in Wohngebieten ein sie attackiert die
Strom Wasser und Energieversorgung und
sie bombardieren Krankenhäuser
tausende Schulen im ganzen Land wurden
bereits beschädigt oder komplett
zerstört
Menschen verlieren jeden Tag ihr zu
Hause Kinder verlieren jeden Tag ihre
Kindheit die Gesundheitsversorgung vor
Ort ist katastrophal es ist dunkel und
kalt in vielen Teilen des Landes
mit der Unterstützung und Höhe von mehr
als einer Milliarde Euro hat die
Bundesregierung im letzten Jahr gezeigt
dass wir unser Verantwortung bewusst
sind diese humanitäre Katastrophe
abzumildern wir schaffen dabei gemeinsam
mit nicht Regierungsorganisationen
Wohnraum für Menschen auf der Flucht wir
unterstützen die Instandsetzung von
Stromnetzen und Wasserinfrastruktur wir
helfen die Gesundheitsversorgung zu
sichern und wir unterstützen darüber
hinaus auch die Nachbarländer molder und
die Ukraine und auch die Länder im
globalen Süden dabei die Auswirkungen
des Krieges zu bewältigen
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich mich
ganz herzlich bei den vielen Kommunen in
Deutschland bedanken die ihre
Partnerkommunen in der Ukraine
unterstützen beispielsweise mit
medizinischen Produkten mit Verpflegung
und Kälteschutz Liebe Kommunen das ist
Solidarität vielen Dank dafür
und während in der letzten Woche und
auch hier im Plenum in der
Öffentlichkeit vor allen Dingen über
Waffen diskutiert wurde stellt das BMZ
und das Auswärtige Amt bereits gemeinsam
mit der Ukraine die Weichen für eine
partnerschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
für ein Wiederaufbau und die spannende
Frage dabei ist wie schaffen wir ein
Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine zu gestalten
denn nicht nur den Zugang zur eu-ebnet
sondern nachhaltig inklusiv und
feministisch ist
und ich glaube persönlich dass dabei
drei Aspekte von besonderer Bedeutung
sind
der erste Aspekt die gezielte Einbindung
der Kommunen und der Zivilgesellschaft
denn die Menschen vor Ort wissen am
besten was Sie brauchen
und die Mitbestimmung von Frauen von
jungen Menschen und marginalisierten
Gruppen ist dabei natürlich unabdingbar
der zweite Faktor der glaube ich wichtig
ist eine nachhaltige und 1,5 Grad
konform mal wieder aufbauen und ich weiß
das klingt gerade irgendwie ein bisschen
grotesk wenn wir jetzt schon über
Wiederaufbau reden aber ja wenn wir über
humanitäre Hilfe reden und darüber wie
es den Menschen vor Ort geht dann müssen
wir auch darüber reden wie wir schaffen
zum Beispiel das Häuser wieder aufgebaut
werden aber mit nachhaltigen Materialien
wir müssen darüber reden wie wir die
Ukraine darüber bei unterstützen können
Energiesysteme aufzubauen die eben von
Wind Wasser und Sonne angetrieben worden
sind und ja wir müssen die Ukraine auch
darin unterstützen einen Umbau zu einer
nachhaltigen Wirtschaft zu haben die
eben auch vor Ort gerade jetzt auch
Arbeitsplätze schafft damit die Menschen
vor Ort ein Einkommen haben
und der letzte Punkt ist es braucht eine
resiliente und krisenfeste Finanzierung
statt Kredite zu vergeben die
voraussichtlich in den kommenden
Jahrzehnten nicht zurückgezahlt werden
können und die Ukraine und auch Moldau
in ein unglaublichen Druck bringen
appelliere ich an unsere Partnerinnen in
der innerhalb der EU mehr Zuschüsse
statt Kredite zu vergeben das ist eine
nachhaltige und vorausschauende
Finanzierung
mit diesen und noch mit vielen vielen
weiteren Punkten können wir gemeinsam an
der Zukunft der Ukraine arbeiten und als
verlässlicher und solidarischer Partner
in auftreten denn liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Solidarität ist viel mehr als die
Debatte über deutsche panzerlieferung
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Thüringen
das nächste Redner das Wort der
Alexander Müller ftp-fraktion und
Alexander Müller ist der
verteidigungspolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Ukraine verteidigt tapfer
ihr Land gegen einen brutalen Aggressor
der täglich brutale Kriegsverbrechen
Kriegsverbrechen begeht Russland darf
diesen grausam und völkerrechtswidrigen
Krieg nicht gewinnen denn es wäre der
Sieg des Unrechts über das Recht das
wäre der Rückfall in eine Zeit des der
Anarchie ohne geltendes Völkerrecht es
wäre das Signal das Staaten sich einfach
mit brutaler Gewalt nehmen können was
sie von anderen wollen wenn wir grenzen
wieder gewaltsam verschieben lassen dann
riskieren wir noch mehr Leid und krieg
die Ukraine kämpft für ihr eigenes
Überleben sie kämpft für ihre Freiheit
und für ihre Demokratie und damit für
unsere gemeinsamen Werte und deswegen
hat sie unsere volle Solidarität
verdient
[Applaus]
es ist gut dass heute eine Entscheidung
verkündet wurde wir finden die richtig
und eine große Mehrheit in diesem
Parlament unterstützt diese Entscheidung
auch was in dieser Debatte ein bisschen
erschreckend fand ist die
Übereinstimmung der Rednerinnen und
Redner von der AFD und der Linken denn
es muss doch jedem bekannt sein
dass es das Demokrat das Diplomatie
nicht weiterhilft es gäbe ohne westliche
Waffenlieferungen gäbe ist die Ukraine
in der heutigen Form nicht mehr und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir die
Ukraine weiterhin unterstützen und ich
bin
vielen dankbar die den Weg für diese
Entscheidung geebnet haben das ist
natürlich meine eigene Fraktion das sind
aber auch Bündnis 90 die Grünen die sehr
früh den Weg dafür bereitet haben es ist
zugegebenermaßen auch die Unionsfraktion
die eine Rolle gespielt hat dabei aber
auch viele Sozialdemokratinnen und
Sozialdemokraten die in einer
schwierigen gewissensabwägung sich ganz
klar geäußert haben die Haltung gezeigt
haben insgesamt haben wir heute eine
gute Entscheidung erfahren und das ist
auch wichtig im abgestimmt mit unseren
mit unseren Partnern international dass
wir diese diese Lieferung machen und wir
brauchen uns auch nicht verstecken
international es ist tatsächlich so all
dieses Gerede dass Deutschland angeblich
zu lahm wäre und nichts machen würde wir
sind international vom Volumen von
militärischer Unterstützung auf Platz 3
und von der finanziellen Unterstützung
mit 28,3 Milliarden sind wir sogar auf
Platz 1 also Deutschland tut wirklich
viel und ich bin im Minister Pistorius
besonders dankbar dass er am Freitag die
Entscheidung getroffen hat konsequent zu
analysieren was haben wir an Ressourcen
was wir noch zusammen
glauben können denn es ist es ist davon
auszugehen dass leider dieser Krieg
nicht im nächsten Monat vorbei ist der
Krieg kann noch lange dauern und wir
müssen einen Plan haben wie wir
konsequent weiter unterstützen können
und die Mittel die wir in der Bundeswehr
abgeben können sind begrenzt und
deswegen ist es richtig dass jetzt
geprüft wird was ist ein gebrauchter
Material da was kann wann repariert
werden und was kann die abgegeben werden
Herr Minister das war eine sehr gute
Entscheidung für die sind wir Ihnen sehr
dankbar
und dann kommen wir
zum zu dieser aktuellen Stunde die uns
die unionsfraktionen heute beschert hat
mit dem Titel kein Vertrauen bei
Verbündeten verspielen man will damit zu
den Eindruck vermitteln die
Bundesregierung würde Vertrauen bei
Verbündeten spielen und das trieft doch
vor Ironie erinnern wir uns doch mal wer
hat denn damals in Wales diesen 2%
Beschluss gemacht das war unter der
Regierung Angela Merkel dass die
Verträge dort die Abmachungen
geschlossen wurden und es ist über Jahre
über viele Jahre nie gelungen an diese
zwei Prozent Ziel heranzukommen das
waren die Verbündeten die uns dafür
immer wieder kritisieren haben wie Lahm
Deutschland ist dass Deutschland seine
Verträge nicht erfüllt da haben wir uns
international isoliert und ich brauche
die ganzen Beispiele doch gar nicht
nennen wir kennen die die Sachen wo die
Welt über uns gelacht hat ob das die
Gosch Fock war das war unter Ministerin
von der Leyen das war die vor 13-fachung
des reparaturbudgets hat viele Jahre
gedauert es war die ausschreiben das
wären transporthubschraubers wo man für
jede Schraube vorschreiben wollte
welches die deutsche Unternehmen die
einzubauen hat es war das Sturmgewehr
die Ausschreibung die aufgehoben wurde
es war die berateraffäre mit
Untersuchungsausschuss die die
Digitalisierung der Bundeswehr über
viele Jahre gelähmt hat es war die 700
Millionen Euro Drohne die nur für ein
Museum entwickelt wurde also wenn es
darum geht dass wir uns international
lächerlich gemacht haben dann waren das
Entscheidungen der der früheren
Regierung aber nicht der jetzigen
Regierung im Gegenteil diese Regierung
hat im ersten Jahr bereits mehr für die
Sicherheit unseres Landes getan als
viele Regierungen vorher wir haben mit
der 100 Milliarden Finanzierung schon
deutlich mehr getan um auf das zwei
Prozent Ziel hinzukommen wir haben mit
dem beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
einen ersten wichtigen Schritt gemacht
die Beschaffung zu beschleunigen und da
werden weitere kommen wir haben andere
Entscheidungen getroffen wie die
Bewaffnung der Drohnen dass Sie unsere
Soldaten in Zukunft besser schützen
können wir haben die Bestellung des
Tornado Nachfolgers in die Wege gebracht
den schweren Transporthubschrauber das
Sturmgewehr all diese Bestellungen
bringen wir jetzt auf den Weg wir an den
Knoten gelöst beim fk-system und wir
werden noch viele weitere wichtige
Entscheidungen nehmen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ganz am Schluss will ich
noch einen Gruß versenden an einen
Staatspräsidenten in Europa der
sinnbildlich wie kein anderer dafür
steht dass es eine Nation eint im Kampf
für Freiheit und Demokratie herr
Präsident selensky herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum 45 Geburtstag vielen
Dank
Geburtstagsgrüße von Alexander Müller
aus der FDP-Fraktion und Jürgen hart
spricht nun als nächstes er ist der
Sprecher für auswärtige Politik der
Unionsfraktion Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich möchte beginnen mit einigen Worten
an die Werten vorräder Lars Klingbeil
und Rolf Mütze nicht mit dem wir bei
viele Jahre ja auch konstruktive gute
Gespräche geführt haben
überlasse ich finde den Vorwurf des
genehles an uns unpassend
wir haben im April diesen Jahres gesagt
es muss Blick auf die Unterstützung der
Ukraine mehr geben als nur 5000 Helme
wir haben dann gemeinsam
einen Antrag Ende April ich glaube zwar
der 28 Bundestag verabschiedet wo wir
das beschlossen haben wir haben dann im
Mai einen weiteren Antrag der cdu/csu
eingebracht hier im Bundestag den haben
sie abgelehnt wo wir gesagt haben wir
möchten das auch schwere Waffen an die
Ukraine geliefert werden wir haben im
September einen Antrag an den Deutschen
Bundestag gerichtet wo wir sagen
angesichts der schwierigen militärischen
Lage müssen wir auch Kampfpanzer zur
Verfügung stellen idealerweise im
Verbund mit anderen diese Antrag liegt
zurzeit Wochen im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
und wird jedes Mal von der Mehrheit der
Koalition von der Tagesordnung abgesetzt
und wir haben letzte Woche Donnerstag
ein ähnlichen Antrag hier wiederum
eingebracht und jetzt macht die
Bundesregierung das was wir seit Mai
fordern
und Herr Mütze nicht beschimpft uns
statt sein Bundeskanzler zu beschimpfen
dass er jetzt das macht weil sie
Opposition will das finde ich also schon
etwas merkwürdig
wir haben uns im übrigen wir haben uns
im übrigen allen Debatten die wir hier
zu diesem Thema geführt haben mit
äußerster Sorgfalt und mit Sensibilität
diesem schwierigen Thema gewidmet sie
haben hier von diesem Pult keinen CDU
CSU Redner gehört in Debatten der hier
in irgendeiner Weise
übergriffige oder unverschämte Anmerkung
Richtung Regierung gemacht hat wir haben
es immer sehr ernst genommen dass es
eine schwierige Entscheidung ist und wir
haben gesagt wir müssen den Mut haben
die zu treffen und wir haben in den
letzten Wochen beobachtet das nicht etwa
der Bundeskanzler andere animiert und
ermutigt hat etwas zu tun sondern im
Gegenteil andere immer lauter und immer
schonungsloser die Forderungen an die
Bundesregierung gerichtet haben nicht im
übrigen Mitglieder der
Regierungskoalition Frau Zimmermann wir
haben gerade in der letzten Woche noch
mal die Auseinandersetzung gehabt dass
das als ausländische Staatschefs und
Verteidigungsminister in Deutschland
angeklopft haben wir haben den Wunsch
abholen gehabt auf Genehmigung der
rüstungsexperte wir haben am weiter
Rammstein gehabt am Donnerstag in der
Debatte sagt Dietmar niethan von der SPD
zu mir ich wüsste ja auch dass am
Freitag beschlossen wird dass die Panzer
kommen ich wusste es nicht Klammer auf
er lag schief ich schlag nicht schief so
wir haben am Sonntag das erlebt dass der
Bundeskanzler neben dem französischen
Staatspräsidenten steht und der
französische Staatspräsident sagt wir
werden nicht nur an dem gemessen was wir
machen sondern auch an dem gemessen was
wir nicht machen das war doch ganz klar
eine Botschaft Frankreichs Deutschland
belebt bewege dich ich finde es gut dass
Deutschland sich jetzt bewegt aber den
Eindruck zu erwecken das Olaf Scholz an
der Spitze der Bewegung stand und nicht
wie es wirklich vereinbremse Häuschen
saß das ist ja nun wirklich eine
ziemlich steile Geschichte
möchte ganz kurz noch
zwei drei Aspekte ansprechen also dass
die das Bundeskabinett heute morgen
beschlossen hat die Panzer zu liefern
woher Pistorius jetzt erstmal
beschlossen hat zu zählen wie viel
überhaupt da sind ist ja auch und wie
eine falsche Reihenfolge ja das war ja
auch irgendwie ein eine doch ziemliche
Hilfsbrücke zu sagen wir müssen erstmal
gucken was wir haben jetzt hat man
entschieden das finden wir richtig es
darf aber natürlich keine Lücke in der
Bundeswehr gerissen werden und deswegen
wäre es gut gewesen wenn die
Bundesregierung vielleicht auch auf der
Basis einer Position die nicht die ich
nicht teil aber die ich akzeptieren
könnte dass sie sagt okay wir wollen
noch nicht entscheiden Panzer zu liefern
aber wir wollen uns in die Lage
versetzen ist vielleicht tun zu können
vielleicht auch als Warnung an Moskau
Moskau du hast es in der Hand ob wir
gezwungen uns gezwungen sehen das zu tun
oder nicht dann hätten wir im Sommer die
Panzer modernisieren können also instand
setzen können Level 1 CO2 die bei der
Rüstungsindustrie stehen wir hätten
vielleicht auch den ein oder anderen
ukrainischen Soldaten schon mal
ausbilden können wir hätten dafür sorgen
können dass Munition da ist und dann
wäre jetzt Entscheidungsfähigkeit
gegeben jetzt ist entschieden worden
jetzt dauert es Monate bis diese Panzer
zum Einsatz kommen und ich hoffe dass
sie nicht zu spät kommen denn der die
früher als Offensive der Ukraine der der
Russen gegen die Ukraine wird ja nicht
bis zum Sommer warten ich stelle ganz
konkret die Frage an die Bundesregierung
wie das jetzt weitergeht in der
konkreten Umsetzung heute morgen im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss und ich habe mir
sagen lassen von den Kollegen
verteilungsausschuss war es ehrlich
haben wir noch nichts gar nichts
konkretes dazu gehört da konnte man
nicht mal die Stückzahl bestätigen also
dass das irgendwie ein großer Plan war
der mit großer Generalität des
Bundeskanzlers vorgetragen wurde und
umgesetzt wurde das glaube ich nicht und
das glaubt auch niemand anders
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege hat Jürgen hart
verweist hier noch mal auf
Ungenauigkeiten ist seine Meinung nach
unter anderem eben wie viele Panzer
überhaupt in in der Bundeswehr gerade
zur Verfügung stehen Robert Vahle ist
fraktionslos unter dementsprechend zwei
Minuten in dieser aktuellen Stunde
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
erstens meiner Meinung nach ist diese
Entscheidung zur Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern an silensky eine falsche
Entscheidung denn sie dreht nur die
kriegsspirale eine Schraube weiter und
wieder werden deutsche Panzer gegen
Russland Rollen das haben dort viele
Menschen noch in ihrem Gedächtnis und
nicht in einem guten
Erinnerung zweitens bei diesem Krieg der
so unnötig ist der niemals hätte
zustande kommen dürfen in der Ukraine
gegen Russland da geht es um die
Verschiebung von Grenzen da haben sie
völlig Recht die NATO verschiebt ihre
Grenzen seit mehreren Jahrzehnten immer
Richtung Russland und zwar die Nähe der
russischen Grenze
das ist die Wahrheit
zweierweiterungserwellen die Russen sind
abgezogen beim 2+4 Vertrag sie
verfälschen doch die Geschichte sie
belügen doch die Menschen in unserem
Land die Amerikaner sind nicht abgezogen
sondern die haben ihre Truppen überall
stehen lassen und ausgedehnt machen
nahtloserweitung nach dem anderen
weder amerikanische noch deutsche
Militärstrategen sind überzeugt dass die
Ukraine den Krieg überhaupt gewissen
gewinnen könnte von den Jubelmeldungen
aus der kriegsteilenpresse
ist lange nichts mehr zu hören
und jetzt haben wir die Situation dass
selbst in der Ukraine der Widerstand
gegen selensky wächst sie wollen das
nicht wissen sie lesen so was nicht sie
sehen sich auch nicht die Videos an die
man sich nämlich ansehen kann wo
Soldaten
und Feldjäger selenskys durch die
Straßen ziehen und Leute bis ins höhere
Alter verhaften um die an die Truppen in
die Front zu schicken bis 60 Jahre es
ist die 7 oder 8
mobilisierungswelle die der durchführt
irgendwann kommt jetzt demnächst und
will Menschen haben dir dort benutzen
kann die USA ich bin jetzt am Ende
jawohl die USA
tun alles um den Krieg zu verlängern es
sterben mehr Russen es sterben mehr es
tut mir leid ich muss Ihnen das Wort
entziehen aber niemandem ist gedient mit
diesem ich muss ihn wirklich das Wort
entziehen der Kollege fahle sie ja
bedauer das auch sehr aber
die Geschäftsordnung geht auch für sie
so letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte ist der Kollege
Michael Roth SPD-Fraktion und Michael
rot ist Vorsitzender des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses
guten Tag Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Abgeordneter Falle das kann ihn nur
der Kreml aufgeschrieben haben aber das
hat mit der Wirklichkeit und mit der
bitteren Wirklichkeit vor allem für die
Menschen in der Ukraine nichts zu tun
das ist heute liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ein guter Tag für die Menschen
in der Ukraine die seit elf Monaten für
ihre Freiheit für Demokratie für
Souveränität und für ihre territoriale
Integrität kämpfen es ist auch ein guter
Tag für den Zusammenhalt des Bündnisses
zu dem Europa die NATO wir viele andere
Staaten weltweit gehören die seit 11
Monaten an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
und dieses Land das einem grauenhaften
angriffskriegs ausgesetzt ist politisch
wirtschaftlich finanziell aber eben auch
militärisch unterstützen und es ist
zugleich liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ein schlechter Tag für das russische
Regime für den russischen Nationalismus
für den russischen Imperialismus der
Europa und nicht nur die Ukraine in
Angst und Schrecken versetzt hat
ich bin heute morgen gefragt worden ob
ich mich über diese mutige und
weitreichende Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung und des Bundeskanzlers
freue ich freue mich nicht das ist kein
Tag der Freude wir sollten uns liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen freuen wenn
endlich die russischen Truppen sich
vollständig vom ukrainischen
Staatsterritorium zurückgezogen haben
wir dürfen uns freuen wenn endlich die
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
beendet werden wir können uns freuen
wenn es zu einem Waffenstillstand kommen
wir können uns freuen wenn endlich die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer wieder in
Ruhe schlafen können weil sie wissen
dieser Krieg ist beendet wenn Russland
nicht gestoppt wird liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen dann droht in Europa
weiterer Krieg dann sind andere Staaten
beispielsweise auch Moldawien von dem
russischen Imperialismus bedroht deshalb
ist ein Sieg der Ukraine nicht nur ein
der Solidarität gegenüber einem Nachbarn
und eine Partner es liegt auch im
nationalen und im europäischen Interesse
dass dieses Land zu seiner Freiheit und
zu seiner Souveränität zurückfindet
ich gehöre einer Generation an die
geprägt wurde von einem Satz
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen
und ich stehe hier gemeinsam mit vielen
anderen die sagen Frieden schaffen mit
Waffen mehr Waffen bringen uns dem
Frieden näher
und
das erleben wir tagtäglich bei den
Kriegsverbrechen Russlands denn es geht
nicht nur darum dass die Ukraine sich zu
verteidigen mag es geht auch darum dass
die von Russland eroberten Gebiete
befreit werden ob in Butcher oder libro
wir haben die schlimmsten Verbrechen
erlebt Menschen sind gemäuchelt worden
es wird ein Krieg gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung geführt und deshalb ist
es unsere Pflicht diesen Menschen
engagiert beizustehen und deshalb
brauchen wir Waffen es ist auch ein Akt
der Humanität aber diesen Satz Frieden
schaffen mit mehr Waffen denn müssen wir
unserer verängstigten und besorgten
Bevölkerung immer wieder gut erklären
und dabei spielt nicht nur die
Bundesregierung dabei spielen auch wir
als Abgeordnete eine herausragende Rolle
weil wir mit diesen Fragen tagtäglich in
unserem Wahlkreisen oder auch in
Gesprächen in der digitalen Welt
konfrontiert werden
nur wenn Putin verliert ist er wirklich
zu ernsthaften Verhandlungen bereit nur
aus einer Position der Stärke heraus der
militärischen Stärke heraus kann die
Ukraine diesen Krieg beenden das ist in
liberalen Demokratien Streit über den
richtigen Weg geht und wir streiten
darüber wir ringen um das Recht den
richtigen Weg zeichnet und aus und
darauf bin ich auch stolz dass wir das
tun aber wir dürfen uns in diesem
Bündnis für die Ukraine nicht
auseinander dividieren lassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen sie uns
darauf konzentrieren den russischen
Imperialismus zu bekämpfen damit haben
wir genug zu tun meine Damen und meine
Herren
ein letztes einige scheinen sich in
ihrem ideologischen Sofa so bequem
eingerichtet zu haben dass sie sogar
noch nicht mal vor der Behauptung
zurückschrecken die Ukraine würde
möglicherweise auch den Einsatz von
Atomwaffen erwägen da will ich noch mal
auf den Kollegen Uli Lechte zu sprechen
kommen er hat das Budapester memorado
erwähnt
1994 hat die Ukraine ihr komplettes
Atomwaffenarsenal an Russland abgegeben
und dafür gab es eine
Beistandsverpflichtung der USA des
Vereinigten Königreiches und Russland
russland hat diesem Land nicht
beigestanden sondern es hat dieses Land
brutalstmöglich überfallen und was wird
zum Schluss brauchen Sie bitte zum
Schluss jetzt ich hoffe sie schläft eine
Botschaft der Hoffnung für die Ukraine
und die kann nur liegen in einem Platz
im vereinigten Europa ich habe jetzt
auch das Wort entzogen es nützt nichts
mehr dass sie was sagen wenn sie keiner
mehr hören kann also es ist unglaublich
[Applaus]
Bundestagsvizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
greift hier durch in diese Aktuellen
Stunde die jetzt ja Ende gefunden hat
mit Michael Roth als letzten Redner
des Abgeordneten rot seine Rede sei wohl
im Kreml
geschrieben worden beleidigt fühlt was
wenn wir darüber nachdenken sollten auch
eher für ihn spricht aber trotzdem der
Kollege sie haben es für 30 Sekunden das
Wort
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident vielen
Dank ich will nur richtig stellen meine
reden schreibe ich selber oder mein
Assistent mit mir zusammen aber niemand
im Kreml und auch nicht sonst wo und ich
weise solche Unterstellungen mit Schärfe
zurück vielen Dank
so damit ist jetzt die Aktuelle Stunde
tatsächlich beendet so das war noch mal
eine persönliche Erklärung von Robert
Falle der hier vor Michael rot
gesprochen hat